We will now transition to Human resources.
Since we are more than an hour behind, we are foregoing our break
to be respectful of department representatives. So we're
self sacrificing today.
We do have a few snacks if you'd like,
but I'm helping with you all with the weight loss program for the
of Houston. As HR is here,
who's running the department.
It's just like a machine, right?
Absolutely. Well oiled. I love it. I love it.
That's how well we do it. Yes. At this
time, I'd like to welcome Director Jane Cheeks and Carla Coleman
as they will provide the human Resource department budget presentation.
Good to have you. Thank you very much. And I apologize in
advance, of course. I know we apologize to you for I get horse on the
day that I have to present, but Carla has my
back. I want to thank you all and
good afternoon, Chair and Vice Chair and Council members.
I, along with Carla Coleman, assistant Director of HR
Finance, are pleased today to present
our FY 23 HR
budget presentation. I'm also enjoying by my executive
staff, which I'll introduce shortly. The city
of Houston has over 21,000 employees
and HR touches every one of them. Whether it's facilitating
health and wellness, enhancing workplace safety,
providing opportunities for training and development,
caring for injured workers, working towards pay equity
or recruitment, and onboarding, we never
forget the human element of our department's
name. Our primary purpose is
to provide opportunities for transformational
public service careers in an efficient and cost
effective manner, all while complying with a
variety of local, state and federal mandates.
Next slide please.
Next slide please. As you can see from our
organizational structure, I have ten divisions.
We will be discussing them more in detail further
in the presentation. But let me pause for 2
seconds just to introduce my team. Elisa Franklin Brocks
is my chief of staff. Darren Hilton is
my deputy director of HR operations.
Carla Coleman is my chief financial officer.
Charles Smith is my assistant Director of Risk Management.
Veronica Davis is my assistant Director of Benefits.
Katina Swift is my chief learning officer.
Velma Laws is the assistant chief policy officer.
Abdi Sdecki is my deputy assistant Director over
Human Resources Information Management. Bob Johnson
is my compensation manager. And Leslie Denton
roach is over HR Communications. And I
would be remiss if I didn't introduce Aisha Roberts as the Deputy
Assistant director over HR operations. And Stefan
Mahal. He's the deputy assistant director.
Director over risk management. I also have the team
that tirelessly helped me put this benefits budget together.
So Carla, would you introduce your team? Yes, my team, please stand up.
The financial team, please stand up.
I can't hear you, I'm sorry. So this is the core team that
actually worked late nights in putting this budget numbers together.
So without them, I wouldn't be able to present here today. So I thank
you and I acknowledge the hard work that they put in.
Thank you, Taylor. Thank you.
Next slide, please.
This slide shows a diverse range of statutes
which we must comply to. Our goal is to administer
all compliance initiatives in a manner that minimizes
risk and maximizes compliance with each statute,
thus shielding the city from potential penalties
and legal cost. Mayor Turner
often speaks about incrementalist. He states
we should be transformational.
We made some major strides here in the HR Department
department in FY 22, one being the
passage of the Prenatal Parental and Infant Wellness Ordinance.
The next one will be one of our largest projects,
the HR One project, which is a collaboration
with Director Kent and the Hits team and Director Piyas
in the Payroll team, where we will implement Success
Factors and Employee central. We are also
implementing a new platform, Benefits Focus,
for our benefits administration. We will make history
with the Benefit Focus implementation by finally ridding
our valued retirees of a paper intensive
process of electing and changing their
benefits. Both Success Factors
and Benefit Focus will offer the mobility
function which is crucial in our digital transformation.
Another major project in HR is zero is
possible. It's called zip. Our safety program.
We have been instrumental in leading safety from top to bottom
by providing all employees, from directors to
frontline workers, with the understanding that zero accidents
are truly possible. We are also implementing several
new technical services to assist us in providing a
higher level of customer service, such as analytical data
through power bi. Next slide.
With our strong commitment to technological advancement,
the footprint we will leave on our organization
will be a model of how HR should
conduct business in municipalities for years to come.
Today we will present our FY proposed budget.
We have reviewed the services that HR provides
to our client department and integrated
all the HR functions residing in the General Fund into
our Central Services Revolving Fund. The mayor's
higher Houston youth program will be the only thing that will remain
in our general fund. This will allow
more efficiency, more efficient
delivery of services for HR.
Now I will turn the presentation over to my CFO
to discuss the budget further. Thank you,
Director Cheeks. And good afternoon,
Chair. Vice Chair. Mayor Per term and council members.
So, what you have in front of you is the functional
chart for HR, which is proposed a budget of $514,000,000 and
it funds 448.7 FTEs.
And this is done through five funds. We have a General fund,
two revolving funds and two Internal Services Fund.
In the General Fund, we are proposing a budget of 1.5 million
to fund 152.7 FTE for the
Hara Houston Youth Program. Then in
the revolving funds, we have the Central Service Revolving Fund,
which the proposed budget is 38 million
and it funds 185 FTE and
the budget is 8% of the combined HR
budget. Then the other revolving fund is the Workers Compensation
Fund, which the proposed budget is 45 million. And it
funds 60 FTEs and it represents 9%
of the combined HR budget. And then from
the Internal Revenue Internal Services Fund we have the Health
Benefit Fund which is budgeted at 428,000,000 and
it funds 51 FTEs and it represents 85%
of HR's budget. And lastly the Long Term Disability
Fund which is budgeted at 1.6 million,
represents less than 1% of the HR's
budgeted fund and it doesn't have any personnel associated
with it. Next slide please.
This is the functional chart for the General
Fund and as I mentioned, the only thing funded here is the Har
Houston Youth for 1.5 million and
it funds 152.7 FTEs or 509
positions. We have expecting 500 interns
and nine career coaches. Next slide please.
This is the central revolving fund for HR and
the proposed budget is $38 million and it
funds 185 FTEs in seven
divisions. We are integrating the HR General Funds
operational functions into this fund,
so we are funding 185 FTEs.
In addition to the HR functions,
core functions that this budget holds, we also have
the budget for contingent workforce and for the training and organizational
development of the city. Next slide please.
This is the Workers Compensation Fund and the proposed budget
is 45 million and it funds 60 FTEs and
three major functions managed by two divisions.
The Safety and the Workers compensation functions are
managed by the HR Risk Management Division and their
mission is to create a safe work environment by eliminating workplace
hazard, reducing the financial impact associated
with the workplace injuries and by being advocates to our injured workers.
Next slide please. This is
the Health Benefit Fund and the proposed budget is
428,000,000 and it funds 51 FTEs
and four major functions managed by four
divisions. This budget houses all the benefit plans
for the city which includes the medical and the pharmacy plans,
the supplemental plans such as dental, vision, life insurance,
life dependent care, flexible spending
and two Medicare Advantage plans for retirees over 65.
Next slide please. And the long
term disability fund, which is budgeted at 1.6
million. It doesn't have any personnel associated with it and
this fund is mostly determined by an annual actuary
evaluation and it happens at year end.
Next slide please. Now this is
the revenue slide for most departments
and this chart compares the proposed budget for
next fiscal year with this current year's estimate.
So I want to say that HR is not a revenue generating department,
so our revenues are products of chargebacks to
the departments for actual program and services
and based on utilization. And also it's a
product of contribution from employees, retirees and
city departments. So this chart shows an increase of
9.5% or 45 million.
Next slide please.
Now this slide covers the key drivers that increases
the proposed revenues, but they are the same key drivers
that are actually increasing the expense sites. So we'll talk
about them later in the expense sites because they're exactly the same as we're
not a revenue generating department. Next slide please.
So this is the expend budget for HR
and this chart compares the FY 23 proposed
budget with this year's current budget. And as you can
see, the 23 budget is proposed with
an increase of 23 million or 4.7%.
Next slide please.
This slide actually has the key drivers for both
the revenue and the expenses. And this 23
million is broken down as follows. So we see first the
General Fund that has a decrease of 2.5 million,
or 62.1%, and mainly this is to the
merger of the HR operations activities and the General
Fund with a Central Service Revolving Fund. So the only
thing left in the General fund is the har Houston youth.
Then the next thing we have is the Central Revolving Fund which
increased by 6.9 million or 20%,
and the increases are due to increased
utilization in temporary service personnel.
And we also added this year the fire department officer
ranking exam for captain and senior captain. We also have
personnel increases due to hope and benefits as well as cost
increases for technology initiatives that Director Cheeks mentioned earlier.
The Workers Compensation Fund increased by 6.1 million or 15%,
mostly due to catastrophic high claims related to COVID.
We also have personnel increases in this fund as well.
And then the health benefit increase of 13 million
or 3.1 is mostly due to premium rate increases of
6.5% from 3.4% last year. We also
have high claim cost in this fund related to
COVID and personnel increases across the board for benefits
and hope. And then the long term disability also has
an increase in rates which increased the budget by 85,000
or 5%. But the increase is mostly due to
participation count increases which drives the claim increases
as well. Next slide, please.
Now in the next six slides we're going to see the HR's budget
allocated between personnel and non personnel cost.
In this slide in front of you, you have the proposed budget combined
budget of 514,000,000. It allocates 7%
of this budget to personnel to fund 448.7
FTEs and this is done with $34 million.
Then the 93% remaining of the budget goes to non personnel expenses
or other expenses for 480,000,000.
Out of this,
480,000,076% is allocated
to claim expenses for the benefit funds.
Then 11% goes to other health benefit
plans which includes supplemental plans and retirees plans. Then it
goes to Workers Compensation claims for 8% and the remaining of the budget
goes to other services, supplies and restricted accounts.
Next slide please.
This one is the allocation of the General Fund budget for Har Houston
Youth, and it allocates 98% of its budget to
personnel to fund 152.7
FTEs, or 509 positions,
and the remainder of the budget of 31,000.
You find it allocated to other services and supplies.
Next slide please.
The revolving funds budget which is set at
38 million, allocates 53% of that budget
to personnel to fund 185 FTEs
and then the remaining 47% to fund the other
person non personnel cost of 18 million. Out of
this, 18,000,087% of that goes to
other services for 16 million and the remainder goes to restricted accounts
and supplies. Next slide please.
The workers compensation fund budgeted at 45 million.
Allocates 15% of that budget to
personnel for 60 FTEs and then 85%
goes to non personnel expenses. And out of this
38 million, which is represent 85%,
97% of that is just claims experience and
the remainder you will find in other services, restricted and
supplies, which is just 13% of that budget.
Next slide please.
Here you see the health benefit which is budgeted $428,000,000.
Only 1% of that budget is allocated to personnel for
only 50 funding, 51 FTEs. The rest of this
budget, which is 422, 87% of
that is allocated to health benefit claims, then 12%
of that is allocated to the other health benefit plans,
supplemental plans and retirees, and the remainder goes to other
services, restricted accounts and supplies.
Next slide please. Lastly, we have
the Long term Disability Fund which has no personnel
associated with it. So 98% of the 1.6
proposed budget goes to fund claims
expenses and the other 2% goes to TPA fees
and actuarial service at the end of the year. Next slide
please. This is
the net change for the General Fund for HR. And as you can
see, HR for this fiscal year has two components, the operational
budget and the Har Houston Youth Program. This budget was
reduced by a net reduction of 20,000 for adjustments
to restricted account, hope and health benefit. It further
has a reduction of 2.5 and that is to
merge the operational activities in the General Fund into
the Central Service Revolving Fund. And the only thing
left in this budget is 1.5, which funds the higher
Houston youth. So the net change from 22 to 23
is a reduction of 62.1%.
Next slide and council members,
this concludes the financial presentations for the budget at
HR, but I pass back to Director Cheese for closing
remarks. Thank you. Thank you, Carla.
Thank you, Carla. I like to thank my
executive staff and every HR employee for
the hard work they put in continuously each day
to service our client departments and council members.
I'd like to thank you also, thank you for supporting us
as we continue to optimize our HR journey.
Do you have any questions for us today? Yes. Council member Abby Cayman.
Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM. First off, Director, to you and your
entire team. Thank you. It has certainly not been an
easy few years. I was looking back over the accomplishments
that you listed and even when I
approached you a few years ago, one parental leave,
which is a massive accomplishment, but even including additional insurance
program benefits like healthy babies,
healthy pregnancy. But on top of all of that,
you dealt with COVID you dealt with implementing a system
for testing for the city you had to deal with. We talked
about NIT Kronos and those issues challenge after challenge
after challenge, and you all continue to serve. So thank you for that.
I also just wanted to, again, just spotlight
my appreciation for you as a director. You always
take our calls. You work with us, of course, under Mayor Turner's
leadership. But thank you for pushing the ball forward for the
city in leading the way again as a city
for the entire country. It's phenomenal. And again, to your entire staff,
I'm looking at a few in particular. It's just a pleasure to work with you
all. So congratulations. Thank you. And I forgot to ask my
department question that I ask everyone. Due to the
financial constraints currently faced by the city of Houston,
what are needs that are not addressed in this budget that you would like us
to be aware of?
What needs that are not?
Wow.
Council Member, I want to tell you, I'm sure everybody
is having staffing issues. And at the end
of the day, HR is not the
same for HR. We are diligently trying
to staff our vacancies, and that's just something that
is challenging not only for the city,
but throughout the United States right now. So we
continue to just make sure that we provide the
highest level of customer service, but we'll continue to staff up.
Well, again, I appreciate everything in the partnership.
Thank you. Thank you. Council Member Michael Kubosh
director Cheeks. This has been a real tough two years for
me and my wife. Yes, sir. And you
know it. Yes, sir. And you were there. You always
took my call. Yes, sir. You always helped
me. And I'm grateful to you and your staff
because it's been a tough time. I broke my leg.
My wife's had four surgeries, been rough.
And I appreciate because a lot of times
I don't know the inner workings of how it goes. So I just go to
you. Yes, sir. Then you
may say, well, and you've never said, I'm not the one to go to on
this. You just fix it. You help me get it together. And I'm
forever grateful for it. And I'm thankful that
you're the head of this department at this time in my life.
God bless you and thank you for your service to our city. And I thank
all of you with Human resources.
Council Member Sally Alcorn. Thank you, chair in the Central Service Revolving
Fund, the $12.3 million in contingent workforce contracts,
can you describe what those are specifically? The one for the general fund.
Go ahead. So we have two contracts, one for the
general fund, one for special revolving fund. We established that last year
when we saw the need of grant funded departments
actually incurring more staffing and we had budget constraints.
So according to those budget constraints
and their operational needs, that's why it's increasing. So primarily
COVID related then? Well, at the beginning, it was COVID related.
We have a lot of grants that are still COVID related for some departments.
Okay. I might ask for some more details on that. In the health benefits fund,
the increase $25
a month, I believe, in the limited plan. Is that just in the Kelsey
plan that employees will be paying $25 a month
more to address the 6.5% increase, or are
those across all plans? So the $25
surcharge, you're talking about $25 as it's described,
for the limited plan. So, yes, it's across
the board. Yes, ma'am. That's an additional additional
towards the premium that employees will
pay in the next year to address the rise in those costs. Yes,
ma'am. And that will be the first time in three years, council Member or Alcorn,
that we have actually had a charge to the employees,
because up until now we have done zero for
the employees. Okay. So the city has been absorbing any
increases and this is passing that one. Okay. I understand $12 on
the health surcharge. There is a line item with the health surcharge,
$2.9 million. What is that?
So those are expenses that we budget for
any wellness revenues that we receive. And so as
we receive it, we have to expense them. So that's what you see in that
line item. I'm not
sure I understand that answer. We're calling it a health
surcharge. $2.9 million,
expense of the account. But those are expenses
that we're budgeting for any wellness.
So there's a revenue component to that equals two expenses.
So if there's any wellness revenue that we receive
for health assessments not completed okay,
that's where I was going. That's people that did not complete their health
assessments, $2.9 million worth of people
that didn't do that. Where's the spouse surcharge? Line item?
It's included in the revenue in the contribution side. For the
revenue side, I'd like to get an amount for that spouse surcharge
that we're getting annually. Thank you. I'll submit the rest online.
Thank you. Director Chiefs, I'll ask a question I
sort of asked the other day when we had our five year forecast and some
of the challenges that we're seeing, not only in the
city of Houston and corporate America, as well as workforce challenges
trying to get new employees, trying to maintain
existing employees.
I'm sure you get involved in a lot of pre employment interviews
and hopefully you're getting involved in a lot of exit interviews to find
out why people are leaving and going elsewhere if they choose
that option. When you talk to people back
years ago when the workforce was a little bit
different and pre COVID, I think a lot of things have
changed. And the reason why I'm saying that I'm trying to figure out
when you interview potential applicants, and I'll ask your department
leaders for this as well, and when you talk to folks about
why they're leaving the city of Houston and going elsewhere,
there's a number of dynamics that come into play.
Salary, vacation.
Some are looking for travel opportunities maybe that they don't get here
at the city of Houston. And family life balance
issues. One of the things we addressed just about a month ago with
parental leave and things like that, that will go a long way to
have us maintain and attract employees.
Where do you see retirement benefits come
into play when you talk to prospective employees or
employees that are leaving to go to corporate America?
That's a very good question. You specifically said
retirement benefits. So in my conversations
with respect to retirement benefits, they are not
normally the driving factor for those individuals that are leaving
the city. Most of the individuals that are actually coming into
the city, sir, they are looking at our salary and our benefits.
A lot of people leaving private sector are attracted to our benefits.
One, because believe it or not, they are cheaper. They are cheaper
than what individuals are paying right out of their pocket in the private sector,
especially because of what the city contributes to those to
that. But as far as the retirement, we are
millennials and I say that do not give them a bad rap.
They are employees who want to work and they work very
hard. They're looking for their money and they're
looking to get paid. And retirement
is not something that they're looking at right away. Let me say it like that.
In my world, people look for
salary, family life balance with proper vacation,
medical coverage, et cetera, and other
issues related to give me my money today and
give me a comfortable living today where I can do
things and have the opportunity to have some time off and spend
with my wife or my husband
when we have kids.
And I believe that the way
we look at the next 30 years with our long term liability in the city,
it's going to continue to grow. And the only
way to not have it grow is to move to a different blended
type retirement plan. But when you do that and you
have the ability to start reducing your expenses, this is
something that's going to happen over the next 30 to 40 years when
a lot of folks like me will be in
another world and not collecting the
retirement pay that we collected or other
employees. So if you address the employees
who are buying salary, who are buying family life
and are not buying retirement,
aren't we losing when we don't raise salaries to compensate
for a decrease on the benefit side?
The benefits being the retirement pay, the defined
contribution benefit plan versus moving
to some type of a blended 401 or what
other states and cities around the United States are doing in the
government sector.
It's a question, but I think it's a question we need to explore
because if our young millennials, as you call them,
are not buying defined benefits and
are buying give me more money today and let me manage
my retirement. We're selling stuff they're
not buying, thus they're not going to come to us. Thus they're going to leave
to go to corporate America where guess what? They will be dealing
with 401, not defined benefits.
So my argument on this, and before I leave
in a year and a half, I'd love to understand what drives
the employees of the city of Houston today. And if
it's because they have a defined benefit plan, I'll be
the first one to say we'll stick with it. But I don't think they're
buying what we're selling. They're not buying the defined benefit.
They're buying give me more money today, give me a good family life
balance, I want some good vacation and I want parental
leave when I have kids for twelve weeks or whatever that is.
What do you think? You see it every day. You're the Director of HR.
I'm not. Well, let me tell you that our pension is
very attractive, sir. And how many different pension plans do we have for employees
that are working today? Is it four or five? It's four.
It's four different plans? Yes, we have four different plans. So the
defined benefit is still good. Let me tell you
just give me 2 seconds or two minutes. No, you have all the time in
the world. No, I know you all are. We're only running late by an hour
and a half. But that's okay. What I definitely want
to emphasize is that I might have answered that a little bit different two
years ago before COVID came. Okay. All right, I might have
answered that. So before COVID
hit, we pre COVID, we did not have that many
people retiring. When COVID started, we had two to 3%
more people retiring. They were like, Listen,
we're going to leave now. But one thing I want
to tell you that really affected this, even the millennials,
is that people now are looking at
their family life different because people died.
Vice Mayor Pro TEM and they're looking at their coworkers
that are no longer here. Mothers, fathers,
sisters, brothers, all of them. They're looking at the fact that
they need to look at work differently.
And I don't believe that it's the defined benefit.
We have done well with the administration raising up our salaries,
stabilizing the pension, and doing all of those
things. What's most important right now to a lot
of people, not just the people that are just coming to the city,
it is truly being able to have that
flexibility here in the workplace. And I want to tell you
that the pension is still very appeasing
to even millennials. It's just that COVID
actually changed the way people think.
Right now, individuals are looking at our benefits from
having more mental stability within the
workplace. Our benefits are making a difference.
Our wellness is making a difference. And that is
actually attracting people because wellness is big in
the private sector. So when they come and see how robust our
wellness program is, how they're looking at our benefits
and how we pay such close attention to the mental
stability of our employees, that is very important.
Because right now in the United States,
how we look at mental stability, whether you are young,
whether you are middle aged, or you are more tenured,
that is something that is being paid attention to. Vice Mayor Pro TEM
she's the Vice Mayor Pro TEM I know,
but my thing is we have four separate retirement
plans. What about studying a fifth plan? And that
fifth plan will be, if you don't value retirement play
on the fine benefit side, then I'm not going to give it to you,
but I'm going to pay you X percent more,
5%, 10%.
What are people going to do? What will people choose my
age? They're going to choose a defined benefit, of course. But I think
the new employees that we're getting aren't valuing again, what we're selling,
we're selling that we can give them more on the base side
and this thing will soften out in a number of years as
you have those employees that retire and move away from
the defined benefit plan. But anyway,
thank you. Just things to discuss. I'd love to have a consultant look
at it and see how this plays not only in the other government arenas,
but also in relationship to where are we losing
the people to? Are we losing them to Harris County? Are we losing them to
Chevron? Who are we losing them to and why are
we not competitive? Is it salary that's
driving them? Because they're surely not going to
leave because we have a great salary
package. Maybe they'll stay for the defined benefit. Council Member Pollard
thank you, Mayor Pro tim, I think that's an interesting point that you're making,
and I think based on an individual's perspective on how
they look at their own life trajectory
and their own savings and their own current lifestyle
and what they may choose. So I think that is interesting from
an HR perspective, though, we keep hearing, like the
great resignation. Does the
city of Houston put forth non competes
for new hires? So if a person comes in
in a certain department,
are we able to put forth a non compete clause
or a mandatory stay clause that if you
get hired here, you must stay for X amount of time, or if
you do leave, you cannot take another job
in a similar field? Are we allowed to do that? Do we do that?
We have worked with the legal department on first of
all, let me answer the question. No, we do not have that in the human
Resources department. There have been some instances that we actually
have had looked at with legal
because of some incentives that are out that
you are asked that, hey, if you take this incentive,
we expect. You to do this, but that is just under some of
the incentive plans. Not a regular hire.
No. Is it allowable, though,
in your conversations with Legal through the years? Is that something that
is permissible? We have not discussed
it under the realm of just regular hires to
the city. So I can't find that out. I'd have to discuss it more with
Legal, but as I said, we have used it with respect to incentive
plans, which are a little different because the incentive is a little bit more
than just coming on board. Thank you. Yes, sir. So I've
dealt with that on both sides. If you pay an incentive up front
and someone agrees to sign a non compete
and they leave to go to a competitor or whatever it is, then you have
the right to go back. But as the State of Texas is a strong right
to work place, good luck,
because it's not going to be enforceable.
Vice Mayor for Tim if you just indulge me. I think it's
very important that we
understand that retention is going to be something that's a
factor here in the city. Okay. And we
have employees that are here, and as we are hiring,
we have to keep the employees that are here in the city.
We have to make them feel like
they are wanted so that they no longer want to leave
the city. I think it's very important to us
as a city that we invest, and we are doing that
within the Human Resources Department in training for
our managers and supervisors. It's very important because
in the statistical data that I have looked at, a lot of people
don't leave because of money. They leave because of
their supervisors and managers. And it's very important that
we make an investment in training. I have a new
Chief Financial I'm sorry, a new Chief Learning Officer that's here that
has set up a very robust program. And we are just looking
forward to training our managers and supervisors
to help with understanding and
being more empathetic as their managers and supervisors,
making sure that they understand how to deal with the employees so
we don't have that revolving door. Yes,
sir. Council Member Pollard on the incentive
part. So, the City of Houston, we have so many
attractions, events, all types
of things that come to our city that we as
a city are a part of, and we could probably package
together as some type of incentive for employees,
whether it's going to certain different
attractions, events, sporting games, concerts,
whatever. Right. The city of Houston, I think, should leverage our
partnership with a lot of these different entities,
whether it's Houston first, whether it's the different sporting
venues or whatever, so that we can find as many
perks to work for. The city of Houston.
That as a company, we're able to offer you
packages to where you may be eligible for this, that, and or third,
for you, your family, or whoever. Right. Just like if you're
in the private sector, they're going to try to think of as many perks as
possible to lure you into wanting to work for them. But we,
as a City of Houston, we have partnerships with everybody, right?
And even as council members, we always get all types of
invitations and all types of different ways in
which we can engage and partake in the things that Houston
has to offer. It would be great to leverage our ability as
a city with all the different entities across the board,
to be able to have packages in place through HR,
to where people who work for the city are eligible to
be able to go to some of these things as well, to make
their jobs and their duties more attractive.
Council Member Pollock, you are exactly correct, and the HR
department has already started that we already have
online. And maybe we need to make sure it's bigger so that our employees see
it. We already have a lot of partnerships with the Rockets,
the Texans for Discounts. And we actually have
on our website a City of Houston's discount page
that shows employees of the City of Houston
about those perks. Now, do we need to do more?
We are trying to do more right now, and we are leveraging
everything that comes to us with reference to giving
our employees discounts from taking the kids to the different
circuses and those type things. So we'll just make it bigger on our web page.
But we are that's great to hear. All right, thank you. We are.
Okay, we have four public
speakers. The first we'll go to is Mr. Doug Smith.
Doug,
star six.
Come on, Doug. You know the gig.
Okay. Jason Oliver. Jason, just come to this mic
right here, sir. Thank you.
I just want to say thank you and congratulations on the
on the paid leave. That's really exciting. And I know it's
something that I've been hearing is really good for the city.
First, something the Finance Department kind
of pushed us toward you all was
a question about a comparative analysis of employee pay.
Has HR done such a comparative analysis on
employee pay across city departments? If so, where can we
find it and what needs have you identified?
And then I have one other question that comes from page
seven. How was that one and a half million for higher
Houston youth decided? And then what outcomes can we anticipate
from significantly increasing that funding? I care a lot about youth programming.
That's really important to me. And so trying to think about how we can expand
higher Houston youth and really kind of build on that,
because that 1.5 million has been static for a
couple of years now, at least. So let
me start with your first question, which I believe was in reference
to the comparative the comparative pay analysis.
So per the financial policy yes,
we just completed that analysis.
So we will be doing a presentation to
this council in the next two months. So we
did it on fire, police and municipal employees.
That has been completed. And now we will
do a presentation as per the financial policy
to council, and that will be made available.
Okay. All right, with reference to higher Houston
youth, and I believe it was council member was it
council member Green that actually started the
1.5 million for talking about the
higher Houston youth. And so that has been something that has
been in the budget for a long time.
The administration would have to raise that 1.5
million. We accepted what was given to us. Of course,
we would be glad to do more with more,
but that has just been what has
been allotted for the youth, for the city
since the institution of higher Houston youth.
And what outcomes could we expect from increasing that funding?
Well, right now we have been able, by bringing higher
Houston youth into the city's budget, we have been
able to increase the number of people of youth
that could come in and work here at the city. So when we
started, we were right at like a little over 400.
Now we're actually able, because it's in house, to bring
in 500 and therefore also bring
in the coaches. We have nine coaches. We believe it's important
that the youth are actually taught
how to, when they go out there, what they have to do.
So we go one step further by actually
having them coming to class, actually showing them what's
expected of them. So that can only be bigger
as our funding increases. Because the most important
thing is that children and youth learn by example.
So we have to be able to teach them to reach them.
Okay. Okay. Sarah Blanding,
1 minute, please.
1 second. I'd love to see how you okay,
I have a couple of questions. You've kind of answered them some way, but I
just want to open the floor to fill in.
What are the city's greatest staffing needs as you see them?
Oh, no, it wasn't okay. What are the city's greatest staffing needs
as you see them? And what would you need not just working within
your current limitations, but let's talk about an ideal
world to increase staffing and retention to fully
meet the needs of the city of Houston. And then along with that
is our temporary employee expenditures are much higher than in
previous years. I know to some extent you've
probably already answered that. Why do you think that is? And how can we
increase retention among city employees? And I'd love to hear the answer. Not just like
working with the loaves and fishes you have, but if somebody performed a miracle
and you actually had what you needed to feed the crowd.
Okay, let me say that
any entity, city government, you are always
going to need more funding at
the end of the day, the city's budget is what we have.
And like you say, if we were given more money,
I'm sure we'd have more people. But we have services
that we have to provide to our residents. And what we have
done is to ensure that we are providing that
level of services to our residents, even with the staffing
levels that we have. Our city employees work hard.
They work smart too. And so it's very important,
if I got more money, the departments I
hire for the whole city, but at the end of the day,
those departments would have to specify the specific
needs. I'm the person that has to get the people in
there. I don't want to I don't want to speak for police
and fire. I can't, because the chiefs
know what they need in their departments. But I'm sure if any
department was the funding was increased,
that would assist them in getting more people.
Again, our city employees are stretched. I say
every day,
they sacrifice what they make, they sacrifice the hours
that they have to be on duty, but they still
provide the level of servants to our residents. So wish
we could have more money, but until then, we're going to keep providing what we
need to provide. Thank you. Mr Bernard
Butler,
last public speaker. Thanks.
He'll ask five questions in a minute, though, right?
Thank you, Madam Director.
Thank you in your department, but apologies,
ladies, I'm going to speak through you.
Let's call a thing a thing. I concluded that all
city departments have been understaffed.
It's no longer about prioritization when
you receive less services. Every citizen should ask when they
call. Thank you. Every citizen should ask when they
call a department, are you
fully staffed? Because this is how communities like mine
become underserved for so long. It's not about great resignations,
it's not about tightening budgets, it's not even about COVID
These things just exposed a situation that existed.
And I will say, at the end of the day, we're citizens too.
But when it comes to where everything
shows up, by the time we get there too many
priorities, but we're already way behind.
Thank you. Thank you.
And directors, thank you very much for your time and your presentation.